the 2018 list of the safest cars is out
this morning just 15 vehicles are in the
highest rating including Kia and Subaru
models that's compared to 69 last year
the Insurance Institute for Highway
Safety made it more difficult to be
named a top safety pick+ no minivans
pickups or many cars got the highest
rating Kris Van Cleave is in Dulles
Virginia outside of Washington with
what's behind the change
Kris good morning good morning this 2018
Toyota Camry is one of the handful of
vehicles I got that coveted Top Safety
Plus pick ranking and it did it in part
because of improved headlights and front
passenger crash protection now these
rankings matter to automakers they care
a whole lot about seeing their cars be
listed as the safest on the roads
raising the bar on safety mat the number
of 2018 models with IIHS is premier
safety ranking plummeted we are trying
to send a message to the automakers that
we do want them to improve the
protection for their customers institute
president adrian lund
we did see a big reduction in the number
of vehicles that earn Top Safety Pick
this year because we raised the bar but
people shouldn't think that vehicles are
less safe they're safer than they've
ever been before a top safety pick+
vehicle earned a good rating in crash
tests roof strength as well as high
marks for crash avoidance technology
high IHS is now demanding better
performance from car makers when it
comes to headlights and passenger
protection in what are known as small
overlap crashes which involve just the
front corner of the vehicle four of the
top 15 this year were made by Subaru we
found Subaru owner Linda Robertson
shopping for a new one heading out the
door I'm always thinking of safety
Subaru has one of the best best vehicles
in my opinion to travel in
and snow 47 vehicles made the Insurance
Institute's second tier Top Safety Pick
for 2018 after it added a requirement
for good or acceptable headlights to
qualify 51 got that ranking last year
the group started testing headlights in
2016 and found most underperform
those 15 cars got there thanks to
optional equipment the good rated
headlights for example do not come
standard on base models and many
vehicles lacked standard crash avoidance
technology that won't become standard
until 2022 still IIHS says the
automakers are scrambling to make
improvements and raise their scores
Norah all right Chris thank you so much